ahora hagamos muchos ejercicios de la
página de khan academy para sentirnos
cada vez más cómodos con distintas
formas de sumar números en este
ejercicio tenemos que seleccionar todas
las estrategias que se pueden usar para
sumar 78 + 9 que tenemos que seleccionar
todas las opciones correctas
la primera opción nos dice que hay que
sumar 77 + 10 y eso tiene sentido porque
aquí en lugar de escribir 78 escribieron
77 que es uno menos que 78 y luego por
acá en lugar de escribir 9 escribieron
10 que es uno más grande que nueve pero
eso sí tiene sentido porque si del 78
tomamos 1 y se lo pasamos al 9 de todas
formas nos va a quedar la misma suma lo
que iba a seguir siendo 78 más nueve
entonces esta opción si tiene sentido 78
más 9 es igual a 77 más 10
y además es una muy buena idea hacer
esto porque aquí nos queda 77 más un 10
bonito y cerrado lograr sumar un 10 es
súper sencillo solo tenemos que sumar
una decena y nos queda 87 ok esto es más
fácil de calcular que esto que teníamos
aquí y ahora veamos la siguiente opción
dice sume 78 y después suman 9 y eso
pues como que no tiene sentido no como
que aquí están tratando al 7 como si
fueran unidades y no decenas así es que
ellos solo escogería esta opción y bueno
vamos a ver más ejercicios selecciona
todas las estrategias que se pueden usar
para sumar 35 más 15 tenemos que
seleccionar todas las opciones correctas
y una de esas opciones nos dice suma 35
5 y después suma 10 y lo que están
haciendo en esta opción es tomar el 15 y
partirlo en dos
en 5 y 10 ok 510 es 15 y es una
estrategia muy buena porque 30 y 55 es
un cálculo que podemos hacer en la
cabeza muy sencillo y nos da 40 y
después nada más tenemos que sumar 10
que nos lleva a 50 así es que esta
opción tiene mucho sentido y ahora
veamos qué pasa con esta opción lo que
ahí nos dice suma 30 más 20 y 35 más
pequeño que 35 pero por otro lado 20 es
5 más grande que lo que teníamos que era
15 ok entonces básicamente aquí lo que
estamos haciendo es del 35 tomar este 5
y pasárselo al 15 para que nos queden 30
y 20 si la resta 5 a 35 nos queda 30 y
si esos 5 celos suman al 15 nos queda 20
entonces esta opción también está bien y
también es una buena estrategia porque
también es muy fácil sumar esto
números 30 20 son tres decenas más dos
decenas y eso pues son cinco decenas o
sea 50 y fue súper fácil calcularlo y
bueno lo único que hicimos fue tomar 5
de este 35 y pasárselos al 15 para que
nos quedara 20 entonces pues vamos a
hacer otro ejercicio selecciona todas
las estrategias que se pueden usar para
sumar 41 más 52 lo que tenemos que
seleccionar todas las opciones correctas
y la primera opción nos dice primero
suma 40 más 52 y después suma 140 más 52
aquí teníamos 41 y lo que hicimos fue
sacar ese 1 vamos a lidiar con ese 1
después lo vamos a tener que sumar más
adelante pero mientras tanto empezamos
con 40 52 y ya después sumamos ese 1
entonces si son iguales aunque hay 41
más 52 es lo mismo que primero sumar 40
52 y al final sumar el 1 nada más
estamos separando este 1 y sumando lo al
final y la razón por la que esta es una
buena estrategia es porque entonces aquí
ya nada más nos tenemos que preocupar
por las decenas que hay 40 más 52 es 92
y después le sumamos 1 y nos queda 93
vamos con la siguiente opción que nos
dice suma 43 más 50 y aquí lo que
hicieron fue sumarle 2 a 41 y restarle 2
a 52 y eso pues si tiene sentido lo que
hay aquí sumamos 2 y aquí restamos 2 y
entonces el valor que nos queda es
exactamente el mismo así es que esta
respuesta es correcta también nos va a
quedar 93 y es una estrategia útil
porque transforma a este 52 en 50 aunque
y restándole 2 a 52 y sumándole 2 a 41
hace que nos quede un 50 que es un
número redondo y muy fácil de sumar